here I go with another at work video I'm
actually look I'm actually at work but I
have just watched the final episode of
season 4 of lower decks welcome to sidre
your SciFi TV movie
[Music]
channel the 10th episode of Season 4
lower decks Old Friends new
planets was Bloody brilliant that's not
just a really good Lower Deck episode
actually it was a good Star Trek episode
if that had actually been live action
and they removed some of the humor that
goes with it you know some of the
swearing Etc some of the silliness but I
actually I like the silliness then that
would just have been a really good Star
Trek episode there was a homage to the
um Wrath of KH all the Genesis actually
creating a new planet there was a throw
back to the uh will weaton Crusher
episode when they did the uh whole flash
thing while at Academy and and one of
his um crew mates sort of died from Nova
Squad um they had made a joke about how
the guy Mao I'm going to go Mao that's
not wasn't his name but moo oh was my
favorite toy when I was a kid I love my
Mao but anyway I love that more than
Lego but anyway how he looks oddly like
Tom Paris
strange I like how lower decks can break
down the fourth wall a little bit I like
the humor but I also really like that
Mike McMahon the guy that show runs it
is a massive Star Trek fan he's a
massive TNG fan we get all of these
Easter eggs we get all these nods all
these homages to All Star trekers
well anybody that says they don't like
NE Trek because it's you know two
kurtzman they cannot say that about
lower decks because it's it is an homage
it is a love letter to the Next
Generation but I really like it as well
because they have moved a little bit
away from the humor as the seasons have
gone on and tried to inject more actual
Science Fiction more Star Trek they've
tried to make it a little bit more of a
proper star Tre show now I would argue
actually the strange new worlds has gone
the other way and started to inject more
humor I'm not sure they should do that
in a live action I think a couple of the
episodes of the season two of strange
new worlds lacked because they were
trying to be funny and trying to think
and then obviously got things like the
musical episode they're trying to be too
quirky I think one episode in 10 episode
season of strange new worlds loex can be
quirky can be funny um but the last
season had like three like fullon quirky
silly episodes I think that was too much
or moments like they were saying like oh
you know Spock was sitting as Captain
chair goes what's be your captain thing
you know in the first episode and and
that was just stupid I didn't like it
and it's not funny it didn't work but
anyway I love that strange new worlds
has some humor I think they've gone a
little bit too far lower decks though
yes they did all the humor very much in
the first couple of Seasons but then
they have started to move back through
the way and start like I said starting
to inject more of the science fiction
element and I think they've got the
balance in season 4 absolutely perfect
it is funny it is still silly it is
still Mariner and Boer and Etc being
those
characters but it's also got some proper
sci-fi it's also got some proper you
know really decent like Space Battles
Etc in it they can do stuff for Lower
Deck and animated they can't do in the
live action and I love that and I'm
going to say something quite dramatic
here I think lower deck might be my
favorite of the current Star Trek
iterations and if it doesn't get a fifth
season I am going to be bloody Furious
so let's fingers cross and hope that
they do the rumor that I'm hearing is
that Paramount is looking basically for
partners internationally with all of the
Star Trek series and that actually
strange new worlds
um it may even have this Thursday's
third season canceled and stripped to a
movie but my understanding is that
that's still not decided yet but there
are elements at Paramount that want to
do that I am hearing that um Legacy is
looking for a partner and that's the
only way it's going to get made is
basically if Amazon agreed to pay a
chunk of the money I am also hearing
more and more rumors that Paramount is
actually probably going to get sold in
the next 12 months or at least broken up
and sold and that Paramount plus might
be the first victim of that so let's see
what happens there's going to be a lot
of business related decisions over at
Paramount in the next 12 months and it's
really I think at least in part going to
depend on how they restructure their
debt over the next six months but let's
see what
happens did you enjoy the final episode
of season four of lower decks get to the
comments and tell me also do you enjoy
the animated Trek or are you very much
in the animation or nothing category you
know some people really hate the
animation they really hate it get into
the comments and tell me what you think
because personally I think it's the most
trekk of all the Star Treks at the
moment I think prodig is damn good as
well but what do you think in the
comments subscribe if you're new to the
channel go over to
patreon.com if you want to see these
videos first for a small contribution
and don't forget to
s.co which is our dedicated
website as always please stay safe and I
see you next
[Music]
time